ikaw our sponsors nature's blend
producers of premium Ethiopian black
seed products if you put her job 10
you'll get 10% off your purchase check
out their links underneath in the
description box or if there is one that
is actually objective which everyone
should be fulfilling I don't see how it
could be objective this is it's nothing
utopian not always it can actually it
doesn't have some utopian so let me tell
you something I always give this example
alright so I want to put it to you say
for example if me and you go to sleep
today yes and we wake up and we find
ourselves say on a plane or let's say on
a train yeah and the people are around
us they're talking to each other yeah
and they're eating food and they're
having a good time
what's the first thing you're gonna want
to know you went to sleep tonight
instead of waking up in your bed you
wake up on a train yeah
so why are you gonna you people around
you eating the conversating what you
want to know what they're eating what
they eat hungry ok so minute so they're
view they've given you some of the food
right so now the train keeps going
forward remember you went to sleep in
your own bed tonight yeah you woke up
and it's on a train I woke up on the
train yes yeah good all right so that's
the first question you're gonna have
right how did I get here and where is
the train wherever it is where is it
going
where is this train going yes I can
someone the train yes so means someone
so what am I doing with a train
I do think these are legitimate
questions it's very legit why why yeah
one song one song I was in my bed yeah
now I'm on a train I get there so he was
thrown into the reality of being on a
train after having not been there before
right but the train in this analogy here
is like life because we've were thrown
into the reality of life okay after
having not been here before and we're
going somewhere we came from somewhere
and we're doing something here you know
I mean yes so we took him when I was a
baby
where was not before I'm saying is that
we've been thrown into life yeah there
was a time where you and I did not exist
and then there was a time where we
existed and we were aware of our own
reality yes so this is analogous to what
I've just explained maybe not exactly
that I just bought this in some extent
insane it's the direct knowledge just a
little bit cool that's all right because
you've been through look one guy called
Martin Heidegger he's a German
philosopher yeah he used his term which
is very interesting it's good
the thoroughness of life he said that
you've been thrown into life you've been
chucked into life yeah because there was
a time where you were not here all right
you did not exist at one point now you
exist and you're in this world and you
can you can put you can conceive of that
reality you can realise your own
existence you I mean there's a big gap
analogy there might be but the analogy
is not going to be perfect but when you
see the questions here right the
question is when you were on the train
whether I come from what am I doing here
or one might go insistant existence your
questions what Karl Popper called the
ultimate questions yeah so now the
questions are still applicable because
now we've come from somewhere yes we're
doing something I will go in somewhere
yeah okay so where we're gonna go well
first of all the first question is where
did we come from that's an important one
it is so here's what I'll say to you
look you came from your parents and they
came from their parents and so on and so
forth but they couldn't be an infinite
regress of predecessors right so there
had to be somewhere we're all fired in
the same way this universe came from
somewhere there couldn't be
infinite regress of universes or causes
because then the universe wouldn't come
into existence right just like they
couldn't be an infinite regress of
predecessors of eyes you wouldn't come
into existence one second one second yes
yes infinite regress to the universe yes
look if we say that you came from your
parents oh yeah and then they came from
their parents what I'm saying to you is
that they couldn't have been an infinite
regress of predecessors of that people
your parents in Paris in Paris otherwise
you wouldn't have never been existed
right because there had to be a place
where it started isn't it in the same
way they couldn't be an infinite regress
of entities before the universe
otherwise the universe wouldn't have
started in the same way once again is it
the same you see the scale yeah yeah
we're just inferring that's how we
happen that's what an inference but the
question is this is that you've you've
got sorry
so you've you've got you've got options
you've got options in front of you so
you've got option one is that the
universe came from nothing option two is
that the universe created itself or
option three is that the universe came
from somewhere right or something so
we're saying okay option one isn't
impossibility because the universe
couldn't have come from nothing yes
option two is also impossibilities sorry
so options option one knows that the
universe came from nothing yeah and
we're saying that it's impossible for
something to come from nothing
yeah tested all the possibilities that
he could come from
yeah because by definition nothing is
the absence of something right
so mathematically even zero plus zero
could never equal one so from a
mathematical perspective from a logical
perspective from an empirical
perspective we have no evidence to show
that something can come from nothing
that postulation is an absurd one it's
an impossible one so the first option is
that something that we came from the
universe came from nothing the second
option is that the universe created
itself yes okay at the start of the
universe if there was nothing yes no
that's what I'm saying it's impossible
because from although all the testing
methods that we have right whoever is
ontological testing methods mathematical
testing methods empirical testing
methods and all of those paradigms all
those fears now zero plus zero always
equals zero
there's no situation in which we have
been able to perceive or test or
validate or prove that something has
come from nothing with our limit seed
yeah but we have we have been able to
show the opposite everything that we
know about everything shows us that from
nothing nothing comes so if we do we
know everything
Noah says that we know everything so
that's a different thing there be usable
recognition thing it could be well I'm
saying to you is that we we we don't
know everything that is but we can know
some things which can never be Janice
Ani
so we might not be able to know
everything that exists in the world but
we can eliminate things that could
potentially exist for example if I say
look a squared circle that's a
contradiction it can't exist right why
do we know that it doesn't exist because
there are two opposite things together
right which cannot coexist and at the
same time life we find out that you
could square a circle because the thing
is this is that how would you come about
trying to find that out you'd have to
reinvent the rules of logic if you
wanted to to delete the law of
non-contradiction I'm being put down see
yeah we could do that but with the thing
is we can't do that smoogle is here it
will be a circular thing because if you
try to disprove logic with logic I mean
I think about it the laws of logic here
the laws of logic that we know now for
example laws of non-contradiction some
of the laws of mathematics somebody even
some of the axioms your answer
no no problem go ahead
it's just like sprinklers Dorner
well can I can I finish off for
obscenity yeah but just to finish off on
a wrapper okay how do you know that was
your door on the other side of the phone
say the name and the phone yeah and are
you are you convinced that I showed or
how Sheree about that and how did you
know that that was definitely a door
couldn't have been someone that sounded
like Eudora Tsuda alright so how do you
how are you aware and how are you sure
that is your door wicked nonce in her
voice
so you employed a probabilistic type of
reasoning you said based on the
variables that I have at hand my
daughter's voice the fact that my
daughter's name appeared on the screen
with the number underneath that I'm
pretty convinced would you say you're
certain that was a reasonable it was
reasonable to believe that was motive it
was reasonable would you say you're
happy to live your life knowing that
that was your door on the other side of
the phone yes all right you see your
standards of and this is something I
want to say about not yourself but
generally about atheism and agnosticism
and skepticism your standards for
recognizing truth when it comes to daily
interactions and transactions it's quite
reasonable I would say you're employing
a probabilistic standard yeah now I want
you to employ such a reasonable standard
when it comes to knowing where you came
from what you're doing here and where
you're going because let me tell you
something if you employ a reasonable
standard for those three questions you
come to the conclusion that there had to
be something with no beginning that
started you you'll come to the
conclusion that you came from that thing
with no beginning uncaused cause the
necessary being existence etc because
it's impossible for that to be an
infinite regress of courses and it's
impossible for there to be an infinite
regress with the Pend of things you will
come to that conclusion
refute that you're still skeptical
yeah I'm skeptical that that was your
door on the other side of the phone you
can't because you don't know yellow you
don't know what hate the thing here's
what I'm saying to you is that you need
to be as consistent with your standards
of truth with the ultimate questions in
life which determine what you're doing
here as you are in your daily
transactions and dealing with for
example getting a phone call from your
door I don't think so
well that's fine you don't have to think
so but what I'm saying is then that
would mean that you're basically
employing different standards for
different truths do that look here's one
that you can do that if you want no
problem but you're deceiving us that is
in my opinion there's over skepticism
when it comes to the ultimate questions
which you don't employ in other spheres
in my view is indicative of inner
psychological reasoning behind it maybe
you want to be agnostic maybe it's more
of a want then something will share
philosophize the reason to get on
Francaise so use my reasonable logical
mind and if I think that the existential
question at the beginning of the
universe
yes it's not there to be seen I'm not
gonna hang more hats but your door
wasn't there to be seen but I can hear
oh no but hold on this is a double
standard here yeah if you see the
effects of the universe and you can
reason lookyou that could have been
someone other than your daughter yes yes
nine see the facts of the of the
you meet Lu here here's the problem okay
you just said I could hear her okay now
you're using one of the five senses to
determine it it's a determiner but you
couldn't see her there's other senses
that were not applicable in that
equation all right but you still came to
the conclusion and there was they could
be reasonable skeptical doubt that I can
employ if I was to philosophize as a
skeptic and say look hold on that could
have been an alien that was speaking to
you on the phone yes that could have
been your wife pretending to be odd or
your husband either you know pretending
to be your door yeah or it could have
been someone else your other door could
have been
you know her friend could be this
reasonable it wasn't empirical it was
reasonable I mean why is that reasonable
why it's original reason to mean why why
because I heard mitosis voice several
many times okay I understand but what
I'm saying to you there is that it can
still be doubted yes okay but you still
you over you override that down yes
because you have enough data to conclude
in your mind probabilistically that it
was your daughter
criticism yeah okay fine some some
degree of empiricism
yeah which can still be doubted because
of the reasons I've just told you major
percentage okay why I'm saying to you is
this yeah in the same way as you've been
able to reason probabilistically that
your doors on the other side on the
phone yes I'm saying to you if we have
now inference to the best explanation
you have different options either the
universe came from nothing and in fact
this idea the postulation that something
can come from nothing it's so absurd
that actually let me tell you from
reading a lot of philosophy no one has
said it and the moment some fool tried
to say it Krauss he was refuted by his
own physicist friends so fantastical yes
it's ridiculous it's it's absurd it's
it's not witnessed by anyone it's not
empirical all of the standards that you
wish to have in order to make a reasoned
judgment about the truth or falsehood of
something were not present in the
postulation that something can come from
nothing and therefore can be rejected
yeah yeah it can't be rejected it can be
Richard tryna ash and it shall be
rejected and it shall be rejected but
don't think so okay look here's the
thing
what's the evidence
okay see you look this is it's a slight
look what you have here is some kind of
a motorcycle I'm not a psychiatrist yeah
I'm not here to you know you know give
you a little drink and and tell you tell
you what your hands
yeah sit on the couch and psychoanalyze
your behavior but if I were if I were
I'd say something I diagnosed you of
some kind of cognitive dissonance you
look you're I say literally you might
have cognitive dissonance because the
reason why I think you might have
tumbled into business because you live
your life one way but your beliefs in
relation to the ultimate questions are
completely contradictory to the way in
which you act you understand my point so
your reason your your faculties and your
instruments of reasoning become
completely like you become an extreme
skeptic when you're dealing with the
ultimate questions and you're not
willing to be that same skeptic when
you're dealing with daily transactions
and interactively transactions we see
all the time the quite benign but
they're not benign you could it could be
a life or death situation right now it
could be yeah if a doctor came to you my
friend and said to you let me ask you a
question right now yeah if a doctor came
to you let's say God forbid here but
your doors on a hospital she needed some
kind of a transfer of blood yes well
let's say she even needed a lung
transplant run and the doctor came to
you and said your daughter needs a lung
transplant and you're the only guy that
can that has matched her you know
whatever and you need to give that would
you get what you give it you would give
it but hold on that doctor he could be
making a mistake my friend yes she could
so I would say to the doctor is there
any other way now he'd say no and my so
he gonna do he go to someone else
there's no time he's saying you've got
one hour yeah she's so intensive care
yes yeah yeah I would acts upon my
instincts
yeah and so undo this thing and save my
daughter's life okay you think you're
saving your daughter's life yeah how do
you know you're saving your daughter's
life because I recently believed the
doctor you said but hold on hold on hold
on hold on yeah hold on no but you think
it's life and death this is after life
and death
he said look you see here the point
you're willing to put your own let's say
it takes it could put your own life on
the line yeah you're willing to
potentially put your own life on the
line and I did anything for your
daughter but this the methods of
skepticism that you are employing in the
ultimate questions that we were talking
about well completely thrown out when
you were dealing with that inquiry
submission it's emotional you said it
was instinctive it's instinctively
emotional not no problem is emotional
and and there's no contradiction between
a good emotional argument and a good
rational one human beings are emotional
creatures find but you still believe the
doctor that so you believe the doctor
because you trust in the doctors
credentials and authority yes because
you have enough you have enough reason
to believe that that doctor was actually
trained and can analyze the data yes
so you see here look I want you to use
that same method of reasoning when we're
dealing with the ultimate choice because
you said something very important you
know what he said you said it was a
matter of life and death yes let me tell
you something my friend honestly yeah
this these ultimate choice questions are
not a matter of life and death
you know they are they are a matter of
life and afterlife yes and you know what
let me tell you something that's an even
more hefty inquiry so you have to let me
tell you one of evidence of this
constant do you have any evidence that
your doctor was actually being come in
this analogy that is a jarful evidence I
have enough evidence as a doctor had I
have looked yes I do do you know why let
me tell you why let me explain let me
show you how let me explain you know why
did you trust the doctor when he was
telling you to do X Y Z once again he's
quite benign it's not benign this was
laughing death
life and death - this is life and death
you trusted him putting your own life at
like why do you trust him people eat
trust look after our health well why did
why did you trust him you trusted him
you trusted him good a person of
authority yes and your mind you reason
it was it was it was an appropriate
action a responsible action to trust his
judgment yes so in other words you
vested Authority in the doctor yes now
what I'm saying is this why do I have as
much conviction as I do that there's an
afterlife because I vest authority in
the authorship of the last and final
message to humankind which I believe is
the Quran have you seen this entity what
I've seen the doctor yes okay you have
certification but you haven't seen what
he has seen horror no but in this
analogy right your doctor who you've
seen it's telling you that there are
certain dysfunctionality is in your
saying your daughter's health that you
have not seen but you've instead only
witnessed the testimony of the doctor
but you have as much conviction in the
testimony as you probably would have if
he had shown you x-rays so I have an
interaction with another human being yes
but you've vested your in now you've
given that human-being authority if the
doctor said look listen to me carefully
listen what's your name again sorry
Charles
Charles he says listen Charles you need
to give your land right now because
you're the only one who went I'm not a
doctor I don't know I'm talking about my
you need to give it it could have an
impact on you yes but it's a life in
that situation and then he says this he
says come into my office I'll show you
all of the reasons why I came to my
conclusion if you would like but that
could slow the process down and it could
also endanger your daughter's life what
would you do would you go to the office
or not
to go
is that what you said to the doctor man
I want to check it what do you see what
I'm saying yeah I think you do think
about it deeply I know this down we
dance I know you sit down
I don't know meat on the bone though you
just review the video when it comes out
think about it twice three times have a
tea think about it fourth time and then
you'll know what I'm talking about how
many times maybe five actually
okay guys you know